to get into the home games for the
raiders fans well they must show proof
of covet 19 vaccinations they can use an
app if they're fully vaccinated but
everyone else has to go through an
alternate screening process orco mana is
live at allegiant stadium with how it
all played out today orco
well christian the clear app which you
can download to your smartphone is what
many fully vaccinated raiders fans will
use to get into a legion stadium here
now for fans who are only partially
vaccinated or underage and can't use the
clear app they'll come to this tent here
that says alternate screening they'll
show their vaccine cards their id's and
while there have been some past hiccups
with both entry systems things seem to
run smoothly today
the silver and black out in full force
to watch the las vegas raiders take on
the chicago bears but before watching
all the action unfold fans have to show
proof of covet 19 vaccination those
fully vaccinated can use the clear
health pass most are happy with it even
with minor connection issues works fine
the only problem sometimes around here
because everybody's accessing the
internet at the same time back of the
line is on the next street over fans who
are not fully vaccinated got a vaccine
not supported by the clear app or are 12
to 13 years old and unable to be added
to the app come here to the alternate
screening tent in lot b despite the
relatively new process and the huge
crowd fans agree things are running
smoothly it was quicker than what you
think it is it's a long line but it's
quick it was a lot faster than i
expected it to be but fans have
different opinions about having to show
proof at all some say it's important i
think it's good for everyone just
because you should check if everything
is legit instead of just going off
someone's word while others are doing it
out of necessity not a big fan of it but
i'm here i'll do what i have to do so i
watch the game but not a fan of it all
and we asked some young fans not
eligible for the shot yet about the
vaccine would you have done it
yeah yeah and why
to go to raider games
now for fans who are eligible for the
vaccine but now have not gotten it yet
they can actually do it here on site at
this tent you can see it says kobit 19
vaccine here you can get your first shot
before heading inside but they as well
as partially vaccinated fans will still
have to wear a mask inside the stadium
reporting live tonight at allegion
stadium orca mana live local now